hello my babies this is episode 94 of
congratulations and it is brought to you
by blue apron blue aprons mission is to
making critical incredible home cooking
accessible to everyone you choose chef's
designed recipes and blue apron delivers
fresh seasonally inspired ingredients
cook incredible meals in as little as 20
minutes I do it all the time and it's
amazing check out this week's menu and
get your first three meals free at blue
apron dot-com / Congrats that's blue
apron com / Congrats to get your first
three meals free blue apron a better way
to cook this episode is also brought to
you by the cash app you already know the
cash up is the number one a finance app
on the App Store what you might not know
is that you can also put cash up in your
wallet with the cash card
it's got boosts it's got great safety
features no credit check needed to get
one we'll talk about this more later on
in the show but download then cash app
for free on the App Store or Google Play
mark what's up guys hi my babies it's
Chris D'Elia here and it's episode 94 of
congratulations the podcast and let's go
over some stuff right now right quick
before we're done we got Los Angeles I
got a big show at The Wiltern coming up
near Thanksgiving then I got some Fresno
date and a Bakersfield date and then I
got st. Louis and Louisville and
Indianapolis so go to Crystal viacom to
see the follow-the-leader tour I got all
I got the [ __ ] truest babies checking
in with my app they're watching me live
right now hey what's up guys I see you
on the app and we got some new [ __ ]
cards right here that we got we instead
of the paper shuffling around now I got
you right here it's right here these are
the cards that I got and they got the
[ __ ] if you want to see on the video
podcast we we got the emojis on the back
of the cards one fire is [ __ ] you
know what I mean maybe one higher with
this maybe want to keep his job but
anyway yeah so I am back I had a long
trip it felt like a log any time I go
more than three or four days on the road
it feels like I'm out and I don't
remember what home is like and I'm
feeling good right now though cuz I got
some new laces on my shoes and that's it
that's the kind of stuff that makes me
feel good I'm 38 and that's just the
kind of stuff that's gonna make me feel
good from now on
the 10th now the tetanus shot it still
hurts
now did I get it [ __ ] ten days ago
yes that does it still hurt yes now am i
mad I got it yes does it does it is it
hard for me to work out yes was I told
that if I just work out it'll probably
make it better yes does it make it worse
mmm yes it makes it worse so I don't
have full range of motion with my
shoulder but I'm doing push-ups anyway
for some reason the thing that hurts my
shoulder the most is jumping jumps have
nothing to do with shoulders but the
body works in mysterious ways even
though it doesn't we just don't know all
the ways it works it definitely works in
a scientific way not in a mysterious way
it's Tuesday the podcast is late today
because or late
late this week because of something I
can't [ __ ] remember oh I was shooting
a game show yesterday which had to be
the it was fun it got fun but man it was
dude it's called tell the truth to tell
the truth and it's with Anthony Anderson
and he's the host and his mom is on the
show and she just talks [ __ ] to him and
then we got a guess who's telling the
truth and I got everything [ __ ] wrong
I thought I was good at this [ __ ] you
know what I actually learned about for
real they'll they'll have three so the
show is they'll have three guys and
they're all they say one of them is an
MMA fighter you got to guess which one
and then the [ __ ] curtain opens up
and it's three guys and you get to ask
him questions and you got to find out
who the who the hell the real MMA
fighter isn't you guess one now when the
curtain opens up you your first instinct
is the best once you start asking
questions and trying to figure out you
[ __ ] yourself up because you're thinking
about it too hard I got everyone wrong
because I was thinking about it too hard
I got every single one wrong and when
the curtain opened up I had it I was
like oh it's that guy and then I was
sorry I think was wrong maybe the guy I
may be Cisco maybe the old white guy
maybe saging I'm it was a girl and I got
I lost the whole time and
some reason they're gonna have me back
they liked what I did so whatever maybe
a boy was funny even wasn't good at the
game but maybe a boy was funny
afterwards I said a and Anthony Anderson
I'm like man I'm bad at it he was like
oh you're horrible ah um so anyway he
was wearing a green suit a black guy can
wear a green suit and not be the Riddler
you know but if your white guy you're
the Riddler um yeah dude he must clean
up Anthony Anderson he does [ __ ] 13
episodes in like five days they just do
that [ __ ] when I did that other one the
the the what's Alec Baldwin one whatever
that what game show is I did I think I
did two of those yeah
dude he does like 47 of those shows in
four days and it's like he just must
make like [ __ ] 13 million dollars for
it and that that's it then he then he
just [ __ ] smacks a reporter then he
makes all the money then he go and then
he goes and he [ __ ] punches a
paparazzi guy and that's a day for him
he shoots two episodes of his game show
and then punches a [ __ ] paparazzi guy
out imagine me and famous for that long
though forty years of just hey Alec
Baldwin hey or whoever Hey excuse me can
I go over here over picture though I'd
be knocking everybody out I would be
doing moves on people like it wouldn't
be punching it I would be getting him in
[ __ ] suplexes and DDT's and [ __ ] I
would be I would do the one where I put
their head in between my legs and just
[ __ ] hold my arms out and I start and
I would start looking at everyone else
when they go ah and they'd be like
what's he doing what are you doing then
I just [ __ ] lean back and smash their
head into their spinal column and I blow
I shouldn't ask for a picture oh and
then it's stand on the couch and I go
like this with my ear dude I'm sorry man
every time I go to Jean Claude Van Dam's
Instagram he's doing a Morse abit pose I
can't even believe it dude he leans this
is his pose every Instagram thing it's
so [ __ ] to lean back on put your in put
your weight on one leg
just be like Here I am son of a [ __ ] so
[ __ ] there's one picture where he's
[ __ ] in front of a an elevator and
he's just jamming dude the guy's G
dude it would be so dope if he had the
littlest penis of all time that to be
the best the biggest alpha has the
littlest penis of all time for sure cuz
he has to yeah so I I was in Miami these
are the places I was Miami I was in West
Palm Beach Jacksonville and then I
always also in Atlanta and for the first
time in and then I didn't hear at one
person say Hotlanta probably because it
was November but so I went to Miami
and I lasted the first show I had in
Miami in a theater I had I did to like
500 Cedars and and they were just like -
they weren't sold out you know this was
a while ago that it was just they were
not a good crowd that I remember I will
never forget that's when one girl oh my
god look at Jean Claude Van Damme in the
grass dude hi guys in 10 to 15 minutes
I'll be live here on Instagram from the
Netherlands don't miss it
and then he has somebody take his
picture and he's so leaning far back wow
that's the most [ __ ] [ __ ] ever JCVD you
know dude he's the kind of guy that
[ __ ] watermarks his own Instagram
when even though we know it's him and
also no one would steal that photo dude
Jean prevent them never wears regular
glasses you only wear shades yo he wears
it he definitely has the kind where he
walks into a [ __ ] walks outside and
they get darker oh there's no doubt he
doesn't have those wow the guy's [ __ ]
ripped unbelievable so I went to so I
went to Miami the show was awesome the
first time I did my am it was not
awesome but we sold it out and [ __ ]
by we I mean me sold it out and did
awesome [ __ ] and then we did and then we
did West Palm Beach improv because it's
the biggest improv in the [ __ ]
country it's got like six hundred and
fifty seats so I did two of those and
[ __ ] sorry but sold both of those
and then I did the Jacksonville and I
think I was like ten six ten tickets shy
of selling that one out and then I did
Atlanta I did two shows there sold over
three thousand tickets so it's all good
anyway
yeah dude I did [ __ ] I did Atlanta
dude I love Atlanta man had a good time
in Atlanta I didn't understand what dude
that thick Atlanta accent is so crazy
that like I had a driver that was like
everyday we're gonna do Amit en la
Atlanta like that kind of [ __ ] and I was
like I yeah I said hey we were gonna
maybe go to LA I'm gonna meet my girl
here we go me in LA man we're gonna be
in Pasadena her manager talking about
but Hannah and I was just like ah haha
[ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ] what he
was saying but he was really nice I
think you can feel someone's niceness
you don't need to hear their words so I
was in Atlanta and we [ __ ] we didn't
do much there were lots of weddings
going on which are probably mistake
every time I see a wedding party oh my
god dude this part is for nothing
they're probably gonna get divorced
deeper deeper yeah so I let's see
but what else is it what also later what
were the shows well my favorite show
West Palm Beach is always a weird crowd
dude West Palm Beach is never there like
The Truman Show dude like it's not a
real town they're always setting up in
Florida they're always they have like
this town center where where the Improv
is and they're always setting up for
some holiday it's so annoying it's like
they're setting up for Christmas now
which is like dude it's [ __ ] November
6th and then after Christmas to PI the
day Center for everything do it they
serve for st. Patrick's Day I swear to
god there's no way they don't set up for
st. Patrick's Day and it's like why are
they doing that you're in Florida
there's no Irish in West Palm Beach they
set up for Labor Day dude they started
for Boxing Day in Canada I swear to God
they don't give a [ __ ]
they love setting up
I've never been there where the shit's
been set up they're constantly setting
up and it's like it's the Truman Show
and I'm Truman and every time I get
there they're like oh okay here you here
you here he is we gotta act like we're a
real [ __ ] place and they're just like
older white people
dude the audiences are fine you know
they're okay there's like pockets that
are good any time you have a comedy club
that's over 400 people it's like hard to
really get going because it's just too
big when you're in the back it might as
well be you like you're watching the
show on TV like that's the thing if
you're watching live comedy and you
laugh it's cool but if you watch live
comedy and you're laughing at home by
yourself you're a [ __ ] lunatic now
I've done it but I'm just saying to be
like watching a special and just by
yourself in just be like yeah like in in
in stand-up LA it's such a live medium
you know it would be it's basically the
equivalent of if you're watching a
concert on at home you're holding your
lighter up or your [ __ ] cell phone
by yourself so sad eating blue apron
just with your lighter
lemmya an mer alone dude I've had that
song stuck in my head the Lorne Order
theme song stuck in my head for [ __ ]
three weeks now doom-doom doom-doom
Tintin dude I love when a show is so 90s
and then it just is so successful and it
keeps going and going and now it's so
funny because because the thing about
that date that show is so 90s that they
did they they can't redo the [ __ ]
theme song you know I'm talking about so
now even in 2018 it's the the song comes
on as a 90s
dong dong dong the bass through we're
for short first of all it's a bunch of
[ __ ] white guys doing the instruments
and that guy comes in it's a [ __ ]
it's a black guy who's six years old
that has a tan button-down shirt and you
just go and he just hits his [ __ ]
pow-pow that simony is tinted glasses
like like John clapping a movie like
them
I need those Law & Order theme song Law
& Order theme song doom doom doom doom
doom doom here we go this is the theme
song this is it come on baby let's play
babies it's not playing here we go is it
not it's not doing it is it plugged in
one fire is it plugged in it's not doing
it one fire god dammit what a [ __ ]
would have [ __ ] you know those porns
were they were there jerking that guy
off and then they stop when the guy has
an orgasm whether they call it ruined
orgasm that's what this is look at this
one's called eight hours of Lauren order
theme it was on mute why was it on
[ __ ] goddamn you here we go here we
go here this is so 90s
[Music]
that's the black guy that's the six
years old with a tan button-down shirt
every time I think of people recording
music in the studio I think there's one
black guy with a tan button-down shirt
you 60 years old
this is the most ninety [ __ ] this is
like it will be this would be like if
there was still a show that like a
sitcom where people turned around to the
camera and smiled and then freeze-framed
and then it showed their name
eight hours of this who [ __ ] uploads
this right now what if you were on what
if you had you know the shuffle it's so
hey this is why I don't listen to
[ __ ] my iPad when I have sex with my
I wouldn't have sex because then it'll
shuffle and and and you'll be like oh
yeah and it'll be like [ __ ] some
really dope [ __ ] by genuine and then all
of a sudden you'll be mid stroking
you're like oh god hold on let me move I
shouldn't put it on shuffle and then
she's like oh yeah change it oh wait
never mind then the base comes in she's
like never mind it's kind of funky
[Music]
that's uh yeah so anyway uh yo this guy
I was watching the [ __ ] by the way
what kind of all over the place but what
the [ __ ] was I looka man Mon drop who's
the guy who [ __ ] I was watching a
sword in scale which you know I like
that podcast sword and scale Luca Luca
mandra it was like Lucas something Luka
Magnotta this guy I gotta watch this
guy's
I got to see everything on this guy
because he was like this gay model that
did porn and then I don't know if he did
gay porn or what but he ended up he was
like so narcissistic and self-centered
and then he [ __ ] he like would torture
cats and then he [ __ ] killed a guy I
was listening his sword and scale and do
it it's like [ __ ] so [ __ ] up he he
put an ad out on Craigslist
dude Craigslist is insane still how its
2018 who's still using Craigslist that's
what I want to know there's millions
there's billions and billions of apps
there more apps there are billions and
billions of apps there are more apps
than the follicles on my hair on the
follicles on my head and if you look
closely at my head you'll see billions
and billions of follicles on my head so
apps start as companies and they meet in
Northern California and they develop
what is known as an app and then
billions and billions of companies will
have more and more apps but yeah so this
guy has puts out an ad on Craigslist and
he's like hey just want
just for one I had something like want
to take pictures of a guy and just want
to see it was like a real vague thing
because like I want you to I have some
some [ __ ] I want you to do and he was
like don't want it's not for pay this is
just for fun
and a guy how about that's basically
what the ad was and the and and a guy
responded yeah I'll do it I mean what
the [ __ ] that's how you know there's too
many people out there there should only
be a hundred million people there
shouldn't be seven billion if a guy can
put a rant on a random [ __ ]
Craigslist ad hey I need somebody to
come over and do some [ __ ] for me just
for fun no pay and some other random guy
will be like I'll do it who is he
[ __ ] Michael Caine I'll throw it I
don't care what it is as long as you
film it I'll do it
so Luka Magnotta which sounds like a
[ __ ] alias to a superhero or a
villain I guess the guy comes over he's
this asian guy he comes over and Luka
Magnotta ties him up blindfolds him and
the guys just chilling with his dick out
and then Luka Magnotta [ __ ] stabs him
with an ice pick over and over again
cuts off his limbs severs his head and
then and then [ __ ] and then has sex
with it
yeah dude like real fucked-up [ __ ] and
then uses all I did was here the
reaction videos to it I didn't see it
but I and the in sword and scale it was
showing like it was playing the audio of
the reaction videos and the guy they're
like oh my god he's using the guy's hand
severed hand to jerk off himself off ah
God first of all now I know it's [ __ ]
up but I mean he's definitely like he
was so crazy that the order of things
were just wrong where he was just like
yo dude first of all get the guy to jerk
you off beforehand no pun intended but
like Jesus so sad but you know he was
like oh god damn it
forgot to get jerked off cut his horn
off well dammit
forgot to get jerked off oh well I'll
just do it manually with his hand dude
that's some sick [ __ ] he's 36 this guy
look at Mike 9 and he's in jail
obviously I think he was Canadian but I
was listening interviews of him and he
was just like you know a lot of people
say I'm just devastatingly good-looking
like he was one of these guys like one
of these guys that like I got to start
talking like this to really become like
the ultimate Alpha I really got to start
talking like this well a lot of people
say I'm devastatingly good-looking you
know a lot people say I'm alpha a lot
people say anytime someone says a lot of
people say about themselves you're a
[ __ ] lunatic you know I know a lot of
people out there say I've [ __ ] really
great hair a lot of people who say they
like my tattoo a lot people say I have a
good build you know it's a lunatic dude
look at this look at this on Craigslist
one fire just drag this up in Sierra
Madre which of course it's in Sarah
Madre looking look first of all it's
called pegging in parentheses Arcadia
which is the city 35 minutes away from
us looking for someone that's a bit on
the dominant side for a pegging
relationship it if interesting if
interested send a pic I am a 45 year old
woman
white male do not contact me with
unsolicited services or offers okay okay
cool hey man you just opened yourself up
for maybe some unsolicited services or
offers dude white male looking for
someone that's a bit on the dominant
side for a pegging relationship by the
way pegging if you don't know is when
somebody puts on a strap-on and they
[ __ ] you in the bottom hat so I suppose
he wants a chick then writing X that's
what pegging is otherwise a guy would
just be [ __ ] you in the butt with his
regular penis um hey man sexually
whatever you want whatever floats your
boat that's cool man that's kind of
[ __ ] up that you got to go to here's
another one looking for my buddy
Long Beach looking for my buddy by the
way is the best
header I didn't read this yet here we go
miss my buddy that it was as us to come
by but it means you said yeah I mean if
you're gonna put this on Craiglist least
[ __ ] spell check it miss my buddy
that used to come by kick back and let
me edge and drain his [ __ ] I'm a 5/8 1/5
185 thick asian build and then right
under it do not contact me with
unsolicited services or offers dude I
mean miss my buddy that used to come by
my favorite part about this is kickback
like when he's letting him edge and
drain his [ __ ] he's definitely not doing
any work like well I don't want to have
to go over my [ __ ] remodeling plans
for my kitchen while you while you let
me edge and drain your [ __ ] bro I want
all that [ __ ] to be out of the way and
done with for the day and then we could
just kick back and you could let my
[ __ ] thick asian build and drain your
[ __ ] dude anytime someone says something
about draining their [ __ ] is hilarious
because you're not draining anything
dude whenever it comes out it's always
like I want to drain it like what is it
a sewer it's your [ __ ] bodily [ __ ]
what else is there you peaked oh wow oh
wow you peeked
Chatsworth here we go you walked by my
car and noticed me and then in
parentheses hard you notice me hard
watched for a short while enjoying the
presentation like yet a [ __ ] pointer
I was nervous but couldn't help but be
more turned on wish you stayed to the
end
I'd love to resume women only no men
please
and under that do not contact me with
unsolicited services or offers first of
all zillions and zillions and billions
and billions of men are going to hit you
up there will be zero women that are
hitting you up especially women that
you'd want they will be fat and ugly
unattractive women with bad
personalities known as gourds I mean
unbelievable these things these are the
best oh boy
not this one no it's not good I like how
some of them are like now we just talked
about how a guy was gonna edge and drain
someone's nuts while he kicked back with
his asian thick-billed and then we read
one and went yeah oh man
oh yeah these are miss connections right
imagine seeing someone the street and be
like I'll [ __ ] it in to say hi I gotta
go run on Craigslist hey man well these
titles some of these titles just seeking
new friends morning hookup enjoy safar
n' she loves electronic dance music hey
here's another one tammy horny male
looking for fun oh that's hot what this
was Tammy and then under it Tammy Katz's
from Eagle Rock we lived on Wikipedia
and brother Brian this is Dan I mean hey
man clean that one up before you send it
out there's no punctuation at all it's
all capitals like he's screaming out
over a [ __ ] waterfall um all right
I'm gonna read so I'm gonna go [ __ ]
pick up these guys I'm gonna read a
[ __ ] dance blue apron yeah a blue
apron is amazing first of all I've been
in blue apron two three times a week and
I love it I love it more and more I
still have yet to have a bad one even
food that I don't think I like I make it
with the blue apron and it's amazing
blue apron delivers farm-fresh
ingredients and step-by-step recipes to
your door you choose chef's design
recipes we deliver fresh
seasonally inspired ingredients cook
incredible meals in as little as 20
minutes it's very quick and very easy
let blue apron do the meal prep for you
making back-to-school easier than ever
dinner in as little as 20 minutes every
week at least three recipes built with
your busy schedule in mind wear blue
apron has done the meal prep for you
prepared sauces spices and ingredients
quick and easy recipe options with
insanely delicious flavors perfectly
portioned ingredients delivered right to
your door skipped meal planning and get
straight to cooking with blue apron get
rid of your grocery list and let blue
apron do the meal prep for you choose
your recipes based on our schedule
upcoming meals smoky chicken hot italian
sausage pizza homestyle beef medallions
maple pan sauce so check out this week's
menu and get your first 3 meals free at
blue apron calm / Congrats that's blue
apron calm / Congrats get your first
three meals free blue apron a better way
to cook it is really good you guys don't
even go to the grocery store just get
blue apron and this send it to you and
it's awesome
okay so SeatGeek getting tickets online
can be far too complicated with hundreds
of sites and varying levels of real
reliability you know all those websites
they're so messed up it's hard to know
who to trust
that's why SeatGeek is the way to go
geek pulls millions millions of tickets
into one place so you can easily find
the seats you want for a price you're
willing to pay there's nothing quite
like being there in person trust me
especially when it comes to comedy shows
and Sikhi SeatGeek will get you closer
to the action for a great value geek is
designed to make your ticket buying
experience easier than ever by searching
multiple ticket sites and grading every
cig every ticket based on value SeatGeek
helps you immediately identify the best
seats that fit your budget plus every
purchase is fully guaranteed so you can
shop for your tickets on SeatGeek
with confidence make seat geek your
go-to ticket source for everything from
sports and concerts to comedy and
theater I said this before but I had
friends that I wanted to come to my own
show and it was completely sold out I
couldn't even really get tickets I
already filled up all my comps and I you
seek seat geek to buy two tickets to get
them in and it was really easy it was
awesome and I was a hero
so download the seat geek
and enter promo code Congrats that's
promo code congrats for $20 off your
first seat geek purchase it's definitely
a mouthful to say that so anyway all I'm
trying to say is put this on your iPad
and then put it on shuffle and if you're
lucky while you're having sex download
that we love in bounty only on him down
pono we love in heaven [ __ ] oh no no no
no no
mm what a [ __ ] is going on here dude my
brother's so weird about this [ __ ] he's
always like hey is it okay if I post
this picture of you and I'm just like
yeah man I don't give a [ __ ] I'm always
just like is that can I post this
picture of you and I'm like bro what the
[ __ ] would I care check this out Wow so
nineties can't even believe it
[Music]
yeah oh did you hear Akon is seriously
trying to wants to run for president
oh my god dude all I've got to say about
that is hey I am Tom and I approve this
message
carnival music imagine having a
president that sang a song called I'm so
paid okay you have you had a lot of
you've had a lot of grand plans are you
going to run for president I've been
thinking about running for 22 running
very seriously but I don't want to just
do it because I feel like I want to
continue what I'm doing in hope that
builds me enough momentum for people to
say you're not what if you run or
imagine that dude dude
do you want more of the same or do you
ran one of year in office
that's for your best interests I really
cut funding and [ __ ] and they're
also I will also increase funding and
trying to help the farmers what do you
want another four years of the same in
black and white
would it be Trump running then yeah do
you want Trump you want more you want
this racist orange man in president no
more of the same I'll open the borders
Donald Trump lies I really do [ __ ] all
those [ __ ] aisle
I'll [ __ ] vote for Akon who gives you
[ __ ] you know who gives a [ __ ] I can't
believe how many people were affected by
that fire to be brutally honest remember
on to be broiler mom
people are [ __ ] friends are leaving
their houses it sucks
God how about those far from an imagined
being in there and [ __ ] fighting
those flames and [ __ ] and just being Shh
oh my god what does it take for a man to
be a [ __ ] fireman that's crazy though
they have the shortest life expectancy
out of any job probably I heard
something like well first of all it's
been 80,000 acres which is like insane
and second of all 80,000 acres and then
also it would go a second an acre a
second
would would flame up an acre you cannot
run it like you do just see it coming
and you and you die you get burned alive
what worse way to go do it
I yeah that's a 31 people have died so
far sad [ __ ] man
these fires are [ __ ] crazy it's so
crazy that they have like we don't have
to worry about like tornados and [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that in LA we had the word
about earthquakes and fires fires bro I
don't that's [ __ ] sad man I was had
to do this benefit I had to cover for
Whitney because she was trying to save a
giraffe and I went to she was like can
you do my spot at the improv I'm
supposed to do a fundraiser to try to
raise money for pit bulls and I was like
alright I'll do it I'll help you out and
I was like ah help pit bulls and I'll
help she was like you literally I'm in
the fire saving animals so if you do
this for me you'll be saving my ass and
you'll also be saving animals and I was
like you know what dude how could I not
do that after I look at now let [ __ ]
12 pigs die instead so I so I went to do
the thing and I was like I got to go
first go still had to go to my family I
had to meet up with my family I had a
[ __ ] family obligation and I went to
go do it and they played these these
benefits and these fundraisers that they
do for comedy shows it's always it's
good cuz it raises money but anytime you
do fundraisers or benefits or a comedy
show it's always for it I mean 90% of
the time it's for something sad
so like you'll be like they'll play and
they'll play a video ahead beforehand
and it'll be like this one were pit
bulls and I was like God in loving
memory this pit bull that died because
another an owner tried to have it fight
another pit bull and then oh like this
people have negative stigma against pit
bull because it's fear-based you know
and this and that and it's you know
exacerbated in the media and I get that
you know like pit bulls are [ __ ]
Swedish it but it's like dude they were
these it was like oh so sad we miss you
doggies and people were crying and then
it was like a ladies and gentlemen Chris
D'Elia and then I go on stage and
[ __ ] eight plates of [ __ ] dude it was
the first time I bombed in a long time I
don't know if I bombed I think I
probably did but
hope it got better afterwards I had to
leave immediately but yeah I mean it was
just doing those fundraisers and
benefits are so hard I but but they get
better as in the night goes on but it
always starts with something sad and
somebody who's not a comedian always
gets up first and makes a speech and
they're like ladies and gentlemen
welcome Harland Williams and then Harlan
Williams wakes up and he's like you dick
ever get caught in a blender and they're
like people are like what my name is
Larry
and you're just like what my friend died
of leukemia you know so anyway shout out
to Harlan Williams he's hilarious uh
actually that guy is [ __ ] hilarious
for no actual reason though that guy is
an anomaly
he's he's unbelievable there's kind of
nobody like him and he's so silly and
there's like no structure but he's so
funny and he murders dude he murders
Harlan Williams he murders so much that
they should play this after his set yeah
so anyway what was it gonna say god i
hate when i forget what the [ __ ] i was
gonna say do it I had a good thing and
it was about it was about the benefit
whatever but by the way also
dude this is a good one we're just
talking about random [ __ ] this I like
the podcast man the [ __ ] Conor
McGregor meme do it I don't even know if
it's a meme yet but this [ __ ] made me
laugh so long this made me make Conor
McGregor one of my favorite people oh
yeah his is [ __ ] notorious not aureus
it's on instagram this [ __ ] one right
here
[Music]
[Laughter]
I mean dude he's in his [ __ ] bathroom
with his with by the way behind me
there's a versace robe there's two
versace rogers robes and he's [ __ ]
soul it i mean he's got to be [ __ ]
drunk or something
but he is looking at himself in his
bathroom and he goes and [ __ ] makes
an eye wink and then and then says all
that [ __ ] that's my favorite person you
are not even like that great you know
Wow thirty six thousand comments ten
million views you are a man you you the
man you are a man Wow there's actually
nothing more Irish than that Wow
I would do that a hundred percent if I
had two hundred million dollars where
the [ __ ] he's got [ __ ] that I'd be
taking videos like that all day long
posting all of them I would have my own
Instagram page just called [ __ ] you [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] I would just be showing my
dick you know what I'll be showing my
[ __ ] I'd be setting the camera up to
make it take pictures for in ten seconds
and then I turn around spread my butt
cheeks and have a go and then I'd pick
the best one and post that one
you are a man good a man you got man you
are a man that's I can't believe there
haven't been that many [ __ ] memes
about that ones like when you get a deal
that best boy you too man you the man
you are a man when when she says my
parents ain't home come over you're the
man you are a man I bet it [ __ ]
sounds pretty sick like this - dude I'm
[ __ ] snow so [ __ ] sure like this I
didn't what do you would say sick only
like that
this [ __ ] suit here we go this is
[Music]
what's dope like that fresh boom boom
boom boom boom ok I gotta read these
other ads here sorry guys
goat if your bike sneakers online let me
tell you you know I'm a sneaker guy ok
listen to me about these sneakers if
you're buying stickers online there's
more than a coin flips chance that the
shoe looking for is looking at is fake
trust me
been burned how can I can be sure it's a
real goat calm is the safest way to buy
and sell authentic sneakers online you
can sell them on there or you can buy
them on there they're the largest
marketplace in the world for authentic
Yeezys Jordans and over 600,000 sneaker
listings they've made the whole process
frictionless and trustworthy they do
this by only accepting sellers with the
best reputation and by verifying all
sneakers to ensure their authenticity
for their buyers so they you you order
the shoes then the seller sends it to
goat and then they check it and then
they send it to you so it's every detail
is inspected from the stitching and
color to the size and weight goat
certifies that every pair of sneakers on
their site matches exact factory
specifications with over half a million
sneakers on the platform and 10 million
users you won't find better prices or
verified 100% authentic sneakers
anywhere else it's great it's it's great
find the perfect 100% authentic sneaker
at Goat Comstock Congrats that's goat
comm slash code plus you'll also be
supporting our show all right but you've
got to go right now before the sneakers
you want to gone when you go to goat
comm / congrats spelled Geo 80 comm /
Congrats it's really great I mean it's
one of the only things - as a guy you
can like pop on or the shoes say guy go
to go and get them square cache you
already know the cache app is the number
one finance app at the App Store what
you don't know is that
and also well you might we might not
know is if you don't listen to this
podcast religiously which you should so
you can also put cash app in your wallet
with your cash card it's the only debit
card that offers instant rewards and
comes packed with premium features not
even a credit card can offer like boosts
save up to 10% instantly at Whole Foods
Wendy's or Chipotle and more of your
favorite spots or even $1 off coffee
every time you swipe your cash card at
coffee shops across the country the cash
card puts you in control of your money
with extra in-app safety features that
let you pause your card with a touch
unlike a credit card there are no fees
ever and a credit check isn't required
to get one so download the cash app now
and get your cash card for free and of
course when you use it when you download
the cash app and enter the referral code
Congrats
you'll receive $5 and the cash app will
send $5 to the times up Legal Defense
Fund it's a true win-win visit the App
Store or Google Play market and get this
app and thank you yeah oh my god the
best part about the Conor McGregor thing
is the caption that he brought is at
Instagram that's it Wow guys the man
guys the man I guess he's buddy with
Shaab shop says he [ __ ] loves them I
don't know him but Wow I don't know did
you guys also see the the e dress elbow
doll that's that's not as good as the
Cristiano Ronaldo on the bust but the
aegis el elbow doll is it look it
literally looks like Montel Williams
it's unbelievable it looks like a
[ __ ] it it looks like a younger Sam
Jackson in the [ __ ] well period
actually in the night cement movie I
mean it's Montell Jordan or William
which one is it I never know one I never
know which one is the one with the talk
show with MS or which one's the other
one that goes [ __ ] this is how I tell
where it's Friday night so loud
you know the people in the booth when
he's saying they were like oh my god
it's a lot trying to just turn it down
done tell him to be quiet it's how he's
saying this right this is how we tell
when it's Friday night the parties ride
and it's how over here on the [ __ ]
west side and then I reached in American
I met two moments and a bit to my cup
because I'm faded cuz I'm faded are you
an OG Mac or I wanna be player this is
the most [ __ ] part it feels so good to
be in my heart tonight just like it
feels so good to be in my hood dude
that's so not gangster to say that I
feel so good to be in my heart tonight
and then I fill it up just describing
what he's doing in within 20 minutes and
also not worth singing about I mean it's
one thing to say it's Friday night and
the other alright cool it's Friday night
[ __ ] yeah do it the party is here on the
west side so I reach for my 40 and I
turn it up designated driver take the
keys to my truck hit the shot cuz I'm
faded honey's in the street save money
or we may hear that it feels so good to
be in my heart today and the gangbangers
forgot about the dryer bye unbelievable
and the gangbangers forgot about the
drive-by yo what's that [ __ ] we were
supposed to do I don't remember it feels
too good in my and my goddamn a hood the
[ __ ] was we supposed to do dark what the
[ __ ] was it felt like it was supposed to
be important this [ __ ]
I don't remember dark it feels way too
good to be in my hood so I done forgot
wow dude
ever since I was a lowercase G oh you
know
here we go now worth it to start like
this just start the song
[Applause]
wow dude the way it starts is amazing
just people at a party for [ __ ] eight
seconds literally dead [ __ ] space
just have it start and have the guy and
then he's just standing next to a chick
and he says bang the TVPA guys dancing
the sandwich oh my god God that song
bangs though ha
when that [ __ ] comes on I don't give a
[ __ ] if you're at a funeral you get up
be like ah man it's so sad that [ __ ]
grandma's dead oh man yeah she was young
too is like 63 god that's sad oh the
[ __ ] you drop the [ __ ] casket and she
falls out a little bit this is how we
tow it grandma fell out of the casket
but it feels so good to be in my yard
tonight except for grandma dude Wow
how about her [ __ ] videos used to be
man they were just in a regular ass
house if this song was made now they'd
be in a [ __ ] house that like the bad
guy and Fast and the Furious we don't
you know what I mean
dude they were you gotta make more
videos in houses bro these [ __ ] all
these rappers and and singers they got
the best houses ever also hey R&B music
videos how about you
have a [ __ ] shot of Salome ax of a
couple slow arguing in slow motion more
ah and then a drink falls and breaks you
know what I mean oh my god the most army
should ever is to have an argument in
slow motion with a marble floor on a
marble floor and the [ __ ] and
somebody's drink falls and crashes to
the ground and it [ __ ] breaks open
and it's like one I make it dreams come
true to a [ __ ] loser uno three I like
that song because it helps you learn how
to count then don't know so far and
you're the only one for me you know five
how far does it go
mins I'm sayin laughs sixteen I'm known
as a no-no a hundred and forty seven and
then we start bagging one
uh-huh and you're like we go [ __ ] got
so high why do we have to start over but
my family's is a singlet Brian McKnight
you ever see that woman [ __ ] American
Idol dude when the guy comes and there
any sings then he's like my family says
it sing like Brian McKnight and it's so
bad I wonder if we could find that
American Idol
no no I'll come on one fires thinks we
can't do it and that's his attitude
that's why he's one fire
good guy sings like like Brian Brian
McKnight here we go here it is
[ __ ] yeah dude first thing that came up
Paula I'm speechless
just listen no thanks thanks for coming
out
Wow it's definitely no oh okay so he's
like lingering with his hand first of
all he's lingering he says no and he
like lingers and smiling which is a
[ __ ] and he's looking at him and he's
got his hand behind his back like do you
sure you want me to go cuz you know did
you make it and then Randy [ __ ]
whatever his name is says it's
definitely a no and then he turned it on
and keeps walking and then here we go we
don't gonna change our minds no look and
then he goes to open the door and then
he said come on now this is him right
now what's the problem by the way thank
you [ __ ] Simon Cowell for saying by
the way what's that problem because then
the guy comes back in now Simon Cowell
what he doesn't know what he's done
right now is he's opened the [ __ ]
door to some of the best TV in [ __ ]
history and of course Simon Cowell when
he says his hands are behind his head
because it always looks like he's
getting the best [ __ ] of all time
family have told me I could sing I know
I could sing really well my family said
I could sing they love you I really
sound like Brandon Knight what my family
has taught my family has told me that
that's not the same like Grammy night my
family has told me that I could sing
like Brian McKnight okay and they're
wrong what do you know any Brian
McKnight songs
[Music]
dude the best is that I mean for my sub
one do you know any McKnight songs and
he doesn't say anything and he just goes
first first and you can hear that when
people sing and you can hear the [ __ ]
nasal [ __ ] he goes my dogs are barking
because I'm saying like Brian McKnight
I mean he couldn't look more insecure
the way he's saying is unbelievable
[Music]
[Applause]
now here's the actual Brian McKnight
singing he's covering a whitney
houston's I have nothing while dude
brian mcknight is this year i didn't
know he was so [ __ ] kind of cool
[Music]
this is just a video of him looking at
the camera I guess he's playing I can't
him does he play looks like he's playing
well I'll get to it
oh so calm now he's cracked his nut bad
all right well I'm close this door oh
it's [ __ ] loose I mean when you
completely amazing to watch her when she
was still like 25 million up okay here
we go it's cool how much respect he has
for her though
[Music]
so good
oh my colors for did you if you listen
to this whole song you don't cry you're
a [ __ ] it'll be great if you took a
sip of coke right now like in um in
between two [ __ ] words man it would
be so dope to be able to sing
[Music]
oh wow
the [ __ ] does he do that
oh yeah yeah he's good dude who wrote
this song I have nothing with Whitney
Houston dude he's so good
somebody wrote under it dude you did was
amazing man I thought he was Thanos from
the thumbnail this racist who wrote that
you know I have nothing with [ __ ]
what's his book I don't know her she
wrote it she's so good because I said I
have nothing one fire said to Ivan get
rid of how did you know what he was
playing because it's only your phone
spot I don't get root get rid of he's
obviously [ __ ] listening then I'm
saying and I'm [ __ ] them on fire is
like playing bejeweled on this phone or
some [ __ ]
I have nothing what if you could sing
well though you can't if you're
listening to this just so you know
nobody you [ __ ] listens to this
podcast can sing
I will [ __ ] tell you right now I have
a nothing nothing nothing dude you know
what this [ __ ] would be is if you
married a girl and you sang good at the
wedding oh that girl [ __ ] get a towel
put it under your [ __ ] girl dude you
don't want to ruin a dress just to be
like I have nothing nothing nothing hang
and the [ __ ] oh no it's like the
Titanic all the [ __ ] tables we're
hitting the side of the wall and there's
to a stop second but you don't hear cuz
you're too in it
I haven't nothing it's Friday night
that's what I'm gonna sing to my [ __ ]
wife when I get married do you like and
I would just like you to know how much I
love you the actually it just sounds
gonna be I'm gonna be like I just want
you to know how much I love you and and
I put together a little ditty I love you
so much and I'll be with you forever uh
band hit it here we go
I wrote this little song for you I love
you so much
[Laughter]
[Music]
when I met you on tinder oh wait it was
bumble yeah
wrote me first and I couldn't read you
on the move because it's always a girl's
job to write you first because they
don't let the men right to purse anyway
love you dude said damn yeah I want to
sing that to my [ __ ] wife to be don't
you know I love ya dude I think pretty
much if I heard somebody else do my
podcast word-for-word I would [ __ ]
hate them I would be like this guy
[ __ ] sucks dude I'd be like y'see you
know I love ya you're so goddamn sexy
love them titties and personality can't
wait to get you to the hotel after this
and plan on having sex except we're too
tired because the party and all the
planning came to [ __ ] bubble and then
we just kind of fall asleep on wakeup
bending
I hate myself dude freaking for real I
would hate this podcast but whatever
dude
I guess that's about it oh wait
let's do Twitter er let's do some
Twitter or questions um do we have some
on fire
mm-hmm what's the worst green room you
ever had by Jeff Wilcox at Jeff Wilcox
whoo boy there's some great comedy clubs
with terrible green rooms first of all
any green room that doesn't have a
bathroom in it is the worst where you
have to go use the regular bathroom
where all the [ __ ] patrons are using
in there like okay I get a picture and
your dick is out like there's one in
Seattle that has that I was like put a
group after me the green room bro um oh
very good question Logan Lego Lego ditch
Logan laga ditch at Logan luggage Chris
Lea is it more CUDA to watch a parade on
TV or actually attend one also our
parades the most CUDA thing in the
planet I mean they're up there for sure
if you're going because you're just
going if you're going to a print first
of all if you're the guy who is like
yeah I'll go to parade if you're sending
up oh we're all going okay I'll go then
you're Kudo but if you're the guy that's
like hey let's go to a parade I'll set
it up Oh get a life but then you watched
on TV my dad oh every Thanksgiving turn
it on I like I just like watching the
watching a parade
I like seeing all the floats I like it I
don't know [ __ ] it don't even watch it I
just like it onto the background every
Thanksgiving kind of watch [ __ ]
Spider Man float around and [ __ ] Manny
Martin at Method manual do I believe in
alien do you believe in aliens I don't
know maybe yeah sure I mean they're
probably it's a big big universe out
there you know what I mean
I think [ __ ] if aliens came down here
though and visited us they would be like
wow no worries here these guys are
[ __ ] morons let's go back to our
planet
don't worry yum-yum-yum-yum-yum boom is
that it
these are [ __ ] no no no favorite
shows on TV who wants to know that [ __ ]
who cares what are you a [ __ ]
favorite shows on TV okay hey Chris
what's your favorite show on TV huh
one time I was hanging out with a chick
and she was like what's your favorite
color and I'm like I'm 32 what do you
mean I should just [ __ ] turn it
around on her bin like what's your
favorite color color she pull us sir
[ __ ] off-color
Ecology bah um anyway uh yeah what's
your favorite color no no no I go like
that when someone asked me that I think
I did that am i special or something
today I don't know don't ever ask a guy
with facial hair what's your favorite
color what's that again oh yeah I said
what's your favorite chair dude I don't
remember [ __ ] if I don't do my bit for
one week I don't remember anything
these meme accounts will go -
congratulations pod memes accounts will
post some [ __ ] I'll be like what the
[ __ ] does this one mean I have to ask
him I look what did I say here and
they're like all you said Daniel
Bedingfield is Perez Hilton with the
mask on and I'm like okay I'm a look I
don't remember that but I hate myself
alright so blue apron check out this
week's menu and get your first 3 meals
free at blue apron calm / Congrats
that's blue apron calm / congrats to get
your first three meals free download the
cash app for free on the App Store or
Google Play market enter rewards code
congrats get five dollars and give five
dollars - times up
thank you everybody for listening
subscribe to the YouTube channel it
always comes out on YouTube a day later
oh and the store is almost back open so
you could check either later tonight or
tomorrow and all the stuff will be for
sale again we were down for like five or
six days
fire and follow-the-leader new dates for
2019 on sale we got and the next one
coming up is that in Los Angeles it got
a big one at The Wiltern de Lucia still
there's still tickets available for the
Late Show and subscribe and rate and
review this show please it helps Boston
Fresno Bakersfield Austin San Antonio
Louisville Indianapolis st. Louis
Boulder Colorado Springs Salt Lake City
Madison Milwaukee Chicago Seattle
Hamilton Windsor at Kalamazoo
yada-yada-yada Cleveland Columbus
Cincinnati at Lexington yada yada
Albuquerque Y for some reason Charlotte
North Carolina Durham Newport News
region here for some reason and anyway
we got it so thank you very much for
listening and remember nothing just
remember nothing from this this is
[ __ ] this is just this was only for
entertainment purposes and not for you
to learn something so see you later
[Music]